this is the launch of the compendium of
us best practices for clean energy and
climate
and energy efficiency the idea for this
compendium was Griff Thompson's of that
about two years ago so the grip is going
to open the mean talk about the
compendium and I just want to introduce
grip he he is the person who is in
charge of climate change and energy
programs at the US State Department in
the Bureau of oceans and he is also the
senior energy advisor he has a long and
illustrious history and I think he
mentioned earlier today that he's been
doing renewable energy for 20 years and
he used to work at USAID now he's a
point source in its day one of the many
fascinating things I think is that he
actually has his PhD in political
philosophy from George Tabb and I think
that becomes apparent whenever you
listen to him talk so I'm just going to
immediately turn it right over the group
thank you very much well thank you very
much Leslie again thank you all of you
for spending time out of this gorgeous
day outside to come here and listen
these panels I want to thank the Yale
rule fellows Yale University certainly a
real a core i want too many things to
maria ellingson leslie hunter and tom
Wyrick for working so argue ously on
these best practices and there's thunder
ives outside i looked all of you grab
down but again the Alliance a of energy
acore were that were the key drivers in
this and they've really done great work
and so we're I'm very happy to be able
to be here at this launch and and Leslie
asked me to give you some opening
comments so what I want to do is kind of
frame the discussion building on the
great climate civis to institute panel
we had right before lunch which I really
think set the tone on terms of what we
need to do to move forward and I want to
start with the words of the late great
Supreme Court justice Louis Brandeis who
in 1932 in a dissenting opinion stated
quote it is one of the happy incidents
of the federal system that a single
courageous state may if its citizens
choose serve as a laboratory and try
novel social and economic experiments
without risk to the rest of the country
unquote
and so I we are here today to launch a
project that indeed celebrates that
courage in those happy incidences and
pays tribute to those states and
counties and cities who are nodal not
only courageous but creative as well it
is a courage based on the promise of
parochialism premise Don the principle
of proximity but this understanding of
local knowledge and local wisdom is
nothing new for in fact in ancient
Greece Socrates himself so that the
people in the city were the primary
source of wisdom and as it was in
ancient Greece it certainly is in
modern-day America and other countries
as well and in matters of energy
environment as will hear throughout this
afternoon in the following panels the
virtues of localism or many and that in
most cases there's those that are
closest to and most familiar with the
social political and economic exigencies
that know what is best now this
appreciation of both the intrinsic and
the instrumental value of the local
experience in wisdom is not well we have
normally come to expect from the federal
government at least routinely and
certainly not from those of us within
the State Department who live and dwell
in this was fail Ian world of the
nation-state but even those of us in the
State Department in this apex foreign
policy institution understands the value
of local experimentation and
decentralized knowledge and while one
may not fully subscribe to the late tip
O'Neill's maximum that all politics is
local one cannot deny that much of what
makes good policy must ultimately pass
the test of the local in fact the State
Department understands very acutely the
dominant global trend that is sweeping
around the globe region by region and
that is the increasing decentralization
and devolution of economic and political
power to the municipality's provinces
and to the states we have come to learn
at the State Department what all of you
have known for some time and that is
what justice brandeis extolled that in
country after country national leaders
are looking to states provinces counties
cities and townships for the solutions
to the
both challenges that confront all of us
in recognition of that fact Secretary
Clinton not too long ago announced a new
Special Representative for local affairs
in the state department to ensure that
our department sufficiently reaches out
to the local authorities to learn the
lessons they have learned and help us
learn as we implement or foreign-policy
the compendium of best practices is
simply a first step along what I think
is going to be a very promising pathway
to a future that is cleaner more
prosperous and more equitable it is an
attempt to bring the best and the
brightest in the US to our partners
overseas in hopes that they may find
value in our efforts however as I'm sure
you'll all agree in order for this
initiative to be truly successful it
needs to do more first of all we need to
deepen it and broaden it within here in
the United States but just as
importantly we need to hear from those
from the outside we need to hear from
and listen to the full throated chorus
of those courageous states and provinces
and cities that have also done creative
work overseas and so we can share their
experiences and learn from them as well
I'm very enthusiastic about this first
step and the theme that will be running
through these panels and I'm hoping that
you you take away and think about
through this afternoon is what's the
next step how do we build on this
momentum how do we move from this first
step to full throat throughout a gallop
into the future and learn from each
other and disseminate this information
we're just the this compendium and what
you're going to be hearing in the next
panels is just the tip of the iceberg
it's just scratching the surface of all
the brilliance and the creativity that
we have in the state and local
governments what do we do next and we
look to you to help help us solve that
riddle and I'm very excited because I
think the implications of what we're
doing here focusing on the state and
local provincial authorities are
profound throughout the Compendium and
I'm sure throughout today we'll learn of
a variegated array of policies and
programs that ultimately form a
constellation of solutions to the
multiple challenge of increase in the
diffusion of renewable end
energy efficiency technologies and
ultimately to reducing the greenhouse
gas emissions in all of our countries
throughout the Compendium and through
the panel discussions will get a
brilliant glimpse at the multiplicity of
experiments that can adequately respond
to the diversity and plurality of the
conditions we face around the world so
again on behalf of the State Department
real the whole project I want to thank
all of you for coming here spending time
with us and to celebrate the sentiment
captured by John Stuart Mill when he
said that it is the free and popular
local and municipal institutions that
provide the peculiar training of a
citizen the practical part of the
political education of a free people
thank you very much
so I'm going to launch right into this
panel just echo a few of Griff's
sentiments I mean we're here to talk
about local solutions and and learn from
them and we have an excellent panel with
us here today to do that I I think it
goes without saying that what we're
trying to achieve here is requires
systemic change that energy is an energy
use requires a whole host of different
players in in a community in a state to
to come together and and and develop
these solutions and I think the members
of our panel here today will will speak
to that we have with us to my immediate
left Keith whelks who is Pennsylvania's
deputy state treasurer for fiscal
operations next to him oh sorry next to
him I'm glad I looked Dorian Dale who is
the energy director and sustainability
officer in Babylon New York and then
George Jung who is the director of
policy with the Vermont Public Service
Board I happen to have a benefit of
knowing knowing Dorian the best and I'll
just make one added comment which is I
made my own attempt this past year to
put a high-efficiency boiler in my co-op
in brooklyn new york it only took me a
year and three months to get my co-op
board to approve me putting a hole in
the roof about the size of Dorian's
thermos so that the water vapor could
could be properly ducted and not duct it
into a shared chimney and and so I have
one of two aspirations either to move to
Babylon New York or or learn from our
panel today about
how to make these sorts of systemic
changes which require co-op boards and
contractors and financers and policy
makers to come together so with that why
don't I turn it over first to Keith and
thank you no thanks thought I was going
last but I'm happens no it's fine I
wasn't going to be working in my remarks
during the first presenters remarkably
enough to actually complete well thank
you very much I may have Pennsylvania
Treasury for inviting us to participate
we're honored to be here excited it's a
great opportunity I was here for much of
this morning's panel and it was a great
launch pad eject kickoff I'm going to
start by engaging in the time-honored
practice of lowering expectations I'm
always I'm always a little skeptical and
a lot terrified when I'm introduced on a
best practices panel number one it
sounds egotistical but actually more
troubling is I'm always certain there's
some Joker in the audience who says
after hearing my remarks you know that's
not even a good practice what I'm doing
is far better and so if I can I'm going
to modify the title i'm going to talk
about pretty good practices let's hope
let me start by doing a little
positioning I'm from the Pennsylvania
Treasury Department that means that we
are in some ways and in some very
significant ways quite distinct from
most of the kinds of organizations and
entities that talk about energy
efficiency and providing support for
energy efficiency we are in a sense not
a program agency okay it's a very
important thing to get on the table that
means that we don't have appropriated
funds from our legislature from the
Pennsylvania General Assembly that are
given to us to carry out programmatic
activities with particular objectives
whether those objectives are to support
energy conservation or anything else
that's not what we do we are an investor
we are essentially a quasi private party
investor entrusted with responsibility
of managing the Commonwealth's assets
and generating return from those assets
for as long as we have them
and they aren't needed by other agencies
to make payments we have a statutory
standard that's imposed upon us when we
manage those monies it's the prudent
person standard most fiduciaries are
familiar with it and essentially in
short obligates us to generate a
reasonable rate of return on any monies
that we hold commentor with the risk
associated with the investment class
into which we place those dollars so
everything I talked about today that
we've done is in the spirit of being a
prudent investor and the bottom line for
this discussion is that that means that
we can't simply get involved in a
project because we like the objectives
that project it can't simply support an
energy-efficiency kind of initiative
because we think the end result reduce
consumption of fossil fuels is a good
result it may very well be a good result
but that's not a good result that has
any bearing on our decision-making so
that's an important first thing to talk
about I'm going to try and run through
fairly quickly a program we're involved
in that were invested in to remain you
know faithful to my theme that were
invested in in Pennsylvania called the
health program home energy loan program
it's a program that we created or was
created about five years ago Bob Casey
was elected treasurer i joined the
office in 2005 Bob Casey told his staff
look we have a prudent person
responsibility so I want you guys to go
out and find investments they're going
to do well for the Commonwealth but I
also wanted to find investments that at
the same time are going to do good for
the people of the Commonwealth in ways
that you could based on my particular
background I was interested in
environmental environmentally themed
investment opportunities and I after
talking to lots of people became
convinced that there had to be some way
that we as Treasury could invest in
energy efficiency plays that were
sufficiently well designed that they
would generate a return that would both
repay our investment create a yield to
us and still be worthwhile to the person
who actually took them up in in short if
you will to borrow a term from from
Hollywood where if you can describe a
movie in 25 words or less which is
called high concept you can get your
movie made if it takes you 20 six words
to describe what your movies about
you can't get funding for so our high
concept was we wanted the amount of
money that homeowners saved from
implementing an energy efficiency
project each month to be roughly the
same as the cost of paying off the loan
for that energy efficiency project if
they could break even on a loan and then
have all returned after the lowest paid
off that sounded like a good place for
us to be invested and so that's what we
tried to do spend a lot of time looking
for someone who might have some thoughts
on how we could do that what we knew was
that we needed a partner both because we
didn't know anything about this space
and and because so I already have more
than two boats not the right needed and
because we don't do retail investing and
also because we have to have a partner
where an investor we're not a program
agency and here's where we got
particularly lucky we found a firm a
consumer lender in Allentown
Pennsylvania that had been doing energy
lending for 12 or 15 years and they
understood what the secret of success in
this field was people who have paid
attention to this area probably know
that there have been many if conceivably
dozens of what I would characterize as
bank based loan programs low and support
programs for energy efficiency projects
that have been created over the past
several decades very few of them have
succeeded but if you haven't gotten any
traction and that's because we believe
that's because most energy efficiency
loans and I drop a footnote here that
we're going to start talking if I have
time to discuss other kinds but most
energy efficiency loans even today are
what we consider to be or what we would
call reactive that is to say that most
of these loads for home improvements are
taken out by someone whose furnace is
broken down on februari third and is
looking at zero degree days for the next
week or two and wants to get a new
furnace in place as rapidly as possible
okay it's not someone who's going to
spend a lot of time trying to figure out
what's the most efficient way to do that
if it's someone who goes to a bank
they're not going to be thinking about
energy efficiency to all they're going
to be getting the loan
and then hiring a contractor to put
improving it so if you want to do energy
efficiency you have to sell that product
and that that sale occurs with the
contractor so one of the first keys that
we understood and was actually taught to
us was that having contractors who are
committed to an energy efficiency
program both because they knew it
believed in it and also because they had
an incentive associated with selling
that program were a key ingredient to
success the investment partner we worked
with happen to be working that way firm
called AFC first financial they had when
we first engage with them about 500
contractors that they had created into a
network they had trained them in these
techniques they had sort of validated
them as competent professional and
ethical and they were working through
them these contractors clearly were
interested in simplicity they're
interested in a product that could sell
rapidly they're interested in something
that a homeowner could understand easily
and they're interested in financing
approvals that could be generated
quickly enough that the homeowner would
say yep let's go ahead and do that so we
entered into a relationship with AFC
first we agreed to after designing the
elements of the program with them agreed
to make 20 million dollars available in
capital that we would use to acquire
loans that AFC first originated that
were energy efficiency themed the
program elements that we agreed upon
were essentially the following um only
Energy Star rated or better
installations would be approved and by
the way I am aware the Energy Star has
got a bit of a black eye over the last
couple weeks but it's still the only
certification program that anyone
recognizes and I think on balance is
probably better than just nothing so but
but four years ago it was much better
than just nothing now they would just be
slightly better than just nothing but
anyway was mud used to be much better
than just nothing so energy star
improvements or better okay 10-year
unsecured loans by the way that is a
term a length of time is essentially
unprecedented in this in this market
space but goes towards keeping the
monthly loan payment low enough so that
we meet the high concept I described
earlier $10,000 maximum and then we were
able to offer a rate that covered AFC's
spread to do the servicing to run its
network to develop training materials
and those kinds of things and a yield
that Treasury deemed appropriate based
on the factor we were using as a
comparable at that time which was fed
funds rate if i'm not mistaken so in the
first year of the program the loans were
at 799 now a lot of people may say gee
709 isn't that cheap i can do less with
my home equity line etc we basically
said you know what we think energy
efficiency is a great idea if you can do
it for less please go somewhere else and
take that money if you can do it with
money you have in a bank and do it in
cash great do it if you want to take out
a home equity line fine do it but there
are thousands and thousands of people
every year who are putting this on
credit cards at eighteen percent we're
doing it through big-box financing it at
more than eighteen or twenty percent
we're not able to do it at all and for
these people and by the way AFC was
doing lots and lots of these loans at
twelve and fourteen percent which is the
basic market rate that we were looking
at that point so this is a significantly
below market rate and yelled yet still
one that allowed treasure to be a
prudent investor okay we flex the rates
a little bit in the following year
because the national interest rate
market changed and we went to 899 but
they're fixed rate so once you took out
a loan that was the rate that you got
for the period of the loan and the
program was very well received we had
lots of transaction volume essentially
all that Treasury was prepared to
support at that time ran the program for
about two and a half three years and in
2008 the state environmental agency
which kind of doubles in Pennsylvania as
the Energy Office came to us and said
just got some funding from the
legislature to support consumer energy
conservation we know about your program
and we'd like to see if we could partner
up so we worked with DDP change the
terms so that we were now actually
bullying what we call buying down the
rates below market so we were using DEP
dollars to offer the loans to homeowners
at 59 not makes me 699 59 and 49 i'll
explain what that is in a minute and
then would buy up Treasuries yield and
the amount that AFC needed to cover its
spread by using DEP program support
dollars so we essentially combined a
sustainable model if you will with a
publicly supported model this allowed us
as i said to offer even lower rates and
we can build in this graduated or tiered
structure that created
sentence so now the sort of baseline
rate of human the 699 was for people who
did the traditional energy star loans
599 were for people who did equipments
that actually clean the top 10% more or
less of the Energy Star lists so now
you're not just energy star you've got
to be the best of the energy star you're
doing more you're probably paying a
little more free installation we're
going to offer you a better rate the
exciting thing we did was build in whole
house principles now to get to 499 rate
you had to agree to do a whole house
audit by a certified auditor and
implement a minimum number of
recommendations off the auditors list
and you can get a 499 loan we push the
maximum at that point up to fifteen
thousand dollars and so in that fashion
we think we created this blend of
incentives and some market steering by
encouraging whole house practices
without resorting to add additional
commanding control we didn't say we'll
only fund whole house of audit loans but
we made it clear that those the ones
that we thought were best and the ones
we provide the greatest level support to
so program has now been in place for
about four and a half five years it has
been but we think our standards are very
very significant success we've done more
than 5,500 loans starting from zero we
have 35 million dollars that we've put
out in loan product and currently
treasury is holding about 22 million
dollars that the rest is sort of paid
off either it's just it's been reduced
or some people paid early and even
though this program started before the
economic meltdown and without one hopes
coming out of the economic meltdown
we're looking at alone alone loss
experience of under one and a half
percent aggregate so we're we're very
pleased with that and it is a straight
unsecured program so that performance is
is we think quite remarkable we actually
think that there are some and this is
entirely anecdotal if not more you'll be
preposterous but we think there's some
reason to believe that there's a
psychological connection that that folks
make when they realize they put
something in as actually
benefiting them that they're really very
pleased about the product had gotten
none of these loans are actually funded
to the contractors until the homeowner
signs off and says yes this was done to
my specifications this is what i ordered
this is what i want so we have a high
level of buying at the outset for a
product that people think is actually
working for them we and we believe it is
working the anecdotal information we
have is that people are saving money on
their energy costs and so the acceptance
is quite significant and so we are
hoping that that's one of the drivers
that that's reflected in the pay down
performance to date now let me try and I
know we have brief times let me wrap up
by talking about some concepts of
broader sustainability sort of economic
financial sustainability this all sounds
great and frankly it is great I'm very
very pleased about the program even if
the state energy money went away and we
had to return to our original rate
structure in theory that's a sustainable
program or a couple generalizations I'm
making here in interest of brevity but
in general that's a sustainable program
but there's a problem being a prudent
investor as we have to be doesn't only
mean that we generate a return on what
we invest in it also means that we have
to observe principles about portfolio
diversification and consult end and
concentration that's a fancy way of
saying we can't hold too much of any one
kind of asset class at the end of the
day these loans wonderful as they have
been for us are still unsecured consumer
loans or as they're better known over
the last three years toxic okay and so
needless to say our financial people are
not ecstatic about having a lot of these
and so there's a limit to how much we
would hold how much paper would hold of
this kind of asset class and and I'm not
sure the financial people at Treasury
was seen this but we actually passed
that limit about three months ago and so
we can't really continue to do what
we're doing now we can't buy many more
of these loans after AFC first
originates them our sources are either
to abandon the program wait till loans
term out and we've got no money back
but that's a long slow process or what's
the obvious solution we sell these
exactly we look for a secondary market
investor guess what these are a unique
asset class they don't exist other than
here okay there are no secondary market
investors for these kinds of loans all
right and if there were the first thing
they'd say is or these are unsecured
consumer loans thanks a lot and so
Treasury is now engaged upon a daring
emprise as we say to sell our portfolio
we've retained an investment advisor we
have some very high level support from
foundations who are interested in our
sort of testing the marketplace we're
working with a consortium of other
states that want to see us develop a
model and a precedent and we hope within
the next three to six months to have
sold our portfolio and started to
establish a market value for these kinds
of loans now that's great but that's
still just Treasury that's just one sale
people have been paying attention to the
sort of national political climate on
this issue may be aware that the Obama
administration has essentially
identified home house retrofits as an
enormous not only opportunity but almost
essential undertaking for the country
and they're talking about millions of
homes or the next ten years being
retrofitted at the cost of billions and
billions of dollars that would in theory
require a sustainable secondary market
not just Pennsylvania Treasury selling
25 million dollars every three or four
years that's not a sustainable secondary
market there are other states and in
fact utilities in other in other parts
of the country who are doing this to a
greater or lesser extent it turns out
and we didn't even realize this at the
time but it turns out that treasury
pensive aim is doing something very few
if any one else is doing we are holding
our loans we are actually serving as our
own warehouse facility we can do that
because they're an asset class we're
happy about their performance virtually
everyone else is doing this cannot hold
their loan so they're doing flow through
sales there there originating loans and
they're selling them immediately because
there's they have to get rid of them
immediately there's only one buyer that
they can turn to fannie mae and fannie
mae currently buys these loans at 13 9 9
and 14 99 that's the yield that it
demands okay
which is exorbitant and not sustainable
because no homeowner is going to take
these loans out at that you're not going
to drive home owners to get into this
area at an interest rate like that so
states are having to buy down or buy up
depending on your perspective to get
Fannie Mae to do this which means
they're expending phenomenal sums of
money programs remain small so there are
other states would like to do this the
first step in those other states being
able to do that it do it is to have a
warehouse facility an aggregator that
could hold loans until they reach a size
that would attract secondary market
investors and then sell them okay well
Treasury's interested in being such an
aggregator and in a sort of robust
neutral market you need more than one
we're talking about a lot of money
moving through but we need at least one
to start with so treasury is also now
working with advisors and the Department
of Energy to explore how to model this
market to determine whether we can be a
warehouse facility for these loans which
would allow other states to be doing it
more robustly and far more cheaply so
let me sort of stop there with that as
the future for us we want to keep doing
this locally we want to sell our
portfolio and want to be able to create
come at least the first what we hope
will be a series of warehouse facilities
that would enable more states to do this
in a way more or less similar do not be
identical it more or less similar for
where we are which fits in with a lot of
goals that we all have no thank you i
hope i didn't run too long thank you
Keith why don't we why don't we go to to
the town of babylon and then we'll go
back up to the to the state level
afterwards storian Bruce we will send
some of our governance people to your
co-op board use the shell not expedite
don't address that I think we're pretty
good at that well okay we in the town of
babylon first and foremost and i think
is critical consideration have a real
action bias we have a real action bias
because we got a young turk who is the
supervisor of the town who's been a long
time environmentalist and who
fundamentally looks at problems
and wants to solve them immediately if
not sooner so it's usually damn the
torpedoes as far as as far as we go on
and a good example of that is we passed
building codes in 2006 requiring Energy
Star standards for home construction and
LEED standards for all new commercial
and industrial construction over 4,000
square feet we had a large developer
named it blumenfeld who was putting up a
tanker mall in our in our Township and
at the press conference he goes up to Ed
and he says pulls him aside this is the
press conference with a groundbreaking
for this big mall and he says up usually
was a tad I want to talk to you about
green and later ed says at a US Green
Building Council gala that he never in
his life had been shaken down so
brazenly in such a public way until the
supervisor says no no I want you to do
this project green and he was so
relieved he said sure of course he
didn't know what he was getting it into
but he just received a Silver
certification for his project and the
short term environmental benefit was
that they opened up a rail spur to bring
in all construction material and take
out construction waste eliminating all
that diesel fuel traffic coming in and
out of the town I can show you that
really reduce the ruffle feathers we
still had certainly a good number of
them and oh by the way there was a
examination of eight major projects that
started out a long island since the year
2000 including a lighthouse project and
Nassau with a large developer call rec
ler which is now shelved and the last
project to start which was at tanger
mall in 2005 was the first and only
project to finish so I I say that yes by
way of illustrating that for one reason
or another and I think there are
probably lots of contributory factors I
think we have been admirably positioned
to really get things done so the next
step we went to after we found out that
nobody's building anything new and we
couldn't save any we can reduce our
carbon footprint that way was to figure
out
to make our town facilities more
efficient and as that was being done by
enesco our supervisor said now let me
hear this again you're going to change
out all our energy infrastructure and
the capital the savings that we realize
as a result of this changeover is going
to cover the capital cost and you
guarantee it and the esco said yep and
he says can you do that for residential
and the esco looked at unlike at three
eyes and they said look you know when
we're doing one of these large-scale
jobs all we have to do is deal with one
slightly eccentric energy director but
when we're doing this on a larger scale
basis we're going to have 300 homeowners
some of whom are ieds so waiting to blow
up on us and I can assure you that is a
case and you know there's a
disaggregated cost it's simply not an
economic model first but the one thing
we knew looking at this particular
business was that this esco was bringing
in sub cons to do the actual work and
they were taking a 30-percent management
fee on top of it so clearly there was a
lot of fat to be drawn upon in this
process and everybody's you know I think
underscored that since this time I think
you're all quite familiar with the stats
in our town thirty-eight percent of our
residential thirty percent of our carbon
footprint is due to residential housing
and 24 to commercial so we have huge
opportunities and if like everybody else
we have these very aspirational goals to
reduce our carbon footprint clearly the
largest scale opportunity is in the
building sector so the first thing that
we set about doing was to figure out how
we might finance a pilot project in our
town we attracted an energy from waste
facility a couple of decades ago called
covanta you might have read an article
about energy from waste facilities in
the new york times last week it's in
Denmark I think they have 29 of them for
five and a half million people and the
United States we have 87 of them for 300
million people we're fortunate in
Babylon to be one of those facilities
and what it's meant in practical terms
is we
than generating 16 megawatts of power
and getting revenues from that we've
been charging tipping fees from
surrounding municipalities and on top of
that at about the same time we wrenched
control of of the carding from the guys
in Brooklyn and so yeah which I talked
so they no longer get the Vig we get it
and so in fact we've turned a collection
of solid waste into a revenue stream for
the municipality and as a result we have
a large solid waste reserve and that's
where this pile of money was sitting it
was capturing very nominal money market
rates so all we had to do is figure out
how to rationalize our funding energy
waste from a solid waste facility so we
expanded our definition or the standard
definition of solid waste thing to look
it up after repeated for you but we
added energy waste by dint of its carbon
component carbon dioxide being twenty
percent carbon ergo solids origins ergo
good enough for us to tap into this fund
and we were off to the races as far as
that aspect of it was concerned then we
had to figure out how we were to
actually build this and at the time
there was a lot of buzz about something
called pays pays you saved and there
were a number of pilot programs that
have been run with utilities nyserda who
is the operational energy unit in our
state have done a white paper and
everybody had been a party to how
wonderful a principle this was including
our powers our authority on Long Island
but when we asked them if they might do
on bill financing for us they politely
politely declined to do so and as a
result we then went back to our own
system and as we were billing waste
collection as a benefit assessment as we
do any any service that we provide
private entities we determined that that
would be the way we
you would bill and we had a robust
software system that did our billing for
us and as a result almost unwittingly we
stumbled across what now is popularly
become to be referred to as pace
programs or property assessed clean
energy programs except ours is really a
base program it's a benefit assessed
clean energy program and I would suggest
that the strength of that is that it
doesn't have that four-letter word in it
tax it doesn't it has the same effect if
the homeowner is not selling their
obligation in a timely fashion and are
delinquent it does revolve to the
property tax to date we've had over 400
participants and hasn't been the case
not an operation as long as Pennsylvania
but it it also means that we are using a
mechanism that's been well established
and validated it was affirmed by the
revenue bond Act of 1933 and is a common
municipal vehicle used across the
country in various ways shapes and forms
i know in pennsylvania where there are
commonwealth and there are more
restraints constraints on localities
doing these kinds of initiatives but
we're we're a home-rule state to a large
degree although red agarwalla the
sustainability officer from New York
City might take issue with how much
latitude to the state actually affords
them again the advantage of being kind
of a backwater as we are in Babylon is
that we've done things again with this
action bias that many people might have
subjected to question so when a
neighboring town went to emulate our
program and they're about twice our size
of town named Brookhaven their in-house
attorney said well this is a violation
of article 8 section 1 of the new york
state constitution which posits that a
public entity may not provide a loan or
a gift to a private entity unless it's
for a public purpose and these are loans
we don't see any public purpose in this
well we took issue with that and in part
we were able to do that because again
getting back to the operational aspects
of why I think we've been able to
proceed expeditiously we have we take
our town attorneys and puts them in a
cage in the corner of town hall and only
let them out when they'll give us
validating opinions on what we want to
do she must be married to an attorney
the I think that again you also have to
look at what you're doing in a program
and think of the worst case scenario so
having been something of a student of
that Great Satan Robert Moses we know
that once you get something halfway done
and it's looking pretty good and it's
already halfway there it's going to take
a heck of a team of horses to hold it
back from getting completed and that's
really what we looked at when we went
operation with our program and people
questioning it we said okay what's going
on here somebody Sue's us what what are
they suing while they're suing a program
that seals up people's houses where
maybe AC heirs saves homewards money
puts people to work oh and by the way is
the revolving fund we get our money back
that's pretty good policy and if you
want to sue us great that's great press
release will get more exposure for it
and frankly at the end of the day that's
the doughnut hole in all these programs
that I think we're still tiptoeing
around and that's how we're actually
going to drive demand after all the
smart money people collect and identify
how these loans get packaged resold to
cetera and so forth you know there's an
awful lot of interest but that interest
is we've seen over the past 30 years has
yet to even begin to reach critical mass
among the actual people who will use
these services and that's the homeowner
and that's why we believe also what
we've done in this Babylon program is
particularly important we like to say
that there are three things that we're
providing the homeowner that's cost
comfort and convenience we are giving
them a one-stop retrofit we're providing
their financing at this point it's only
three percent we're going to have to
ratchet that up a little bit if we want
Apache disease won't simply sell them so
that's that's a nice attraction
obviously is a benefit assess loan if
they leave before the term of the
obligation the balance of the obligation
gets assigned to the property ergo the
next property owner picks it up and out
on the hook for you know X number of
years we also qualify all our
contractors they're all Building
Performance contractors and rather than
use a single homeowner dealing with a
home improving contractor when he comes
up short on what you think he should be
doing you have the good auspices of the
entire town to bring down upon the
shoulders of set you know
underperforming contractor because
obviously if he's only dealing with you
he can go through small claims court and
you know make you wait forever but if
he's got dozens of jobs that he's
dependent on from the town he responds
very quickly and I can assure you that's
exactly what's happened in circumstances
where people have in fact had issues and
the other beauty is we're also running a
program and this is I don't know how
when was the last time you receive
services or products from somebody you
didn't like them and then in November
you actually got to step into a booth to
vote to fire the CEO of that operation
that's in effect what you get to do when
you have these municipal administered
operations so people ask us about the
cost of actually administering this and
we've just absorbed that into the cost
of doing town business we pick up your
garbage we shovel your streets we fill
your potholes and now we're sealing up
the cracks and crevices in your house as
a part of doing town business it means
that we also have decided program
discipline our average jobs are running
close to a two-point osir savings to
investment ratio so in effect and we've
already established that the savings do
cover the cost of the loans we also were
very vigorous in bringing in all the
stakeholders we brought in the unions we
the contractors we brought in the local
bankers in real estate folks who might
customarily have objected and we got
signed off so we haven't had really
anybody taking issue the only challenges
we've had are those neighboring towns
you know who've been interested in the
aspirational aspects of doing these
programs but somehow can't get out of
their way when they actually get down to
trying to figure out how they are going
to be go go operational so this has been
one of our challenges because there are
neighboring towns who have been
launching their programs and been asking
us for advice but at the end of the day
we really are fortunate in the town that
standards of aligned and we have a very
entrepreneurial spirit and a few capable
guys who are willing to actually you
know hit the ground running and get
things done a lot of other things I
could tell you but I think I'm gonna
pass it along Dorian thank you very much
another church oh by the way on the
issue of best practices we collect
suboptimal practices although oho it's
it's really kind of a touchy issue
because while I'm one of the few people
who seems to get away with telling
people what's what most people really
don't like to hear it and and when
you're working for a politician he gets
really nervous when you do tell people
these things so thank you thanks well
we're going to switch from energy
efficiency investments to renewables
here with I guess the topic is feed-in
tariffs and where I'm actually going to
focus on what we have which is a little
different scald a standard offer program
basically as an overview Vermont's been
trying for in the Vermont legislature in
particular been trying for a number of
years to encourage renewable energy
development when a number of other New
England states started pursuing
renewable portfolio standards Vermont
looked at and said gee that's a nice
idea but we're not sure we want to go
that far because it might raise costs
for people so eventually in 2005 we put
in a system
there is a renewable portfolio standard
that doesn't take effect till 2013 but
the legislature decided to create a
carrot and stick the stick is there the
RPS the carrot piece was what was called
the speed program I always had to
remember what the this acronym means
sustainably priced energy enterprise
development program basically it's in
they set up a a program which says if
you can get me tall low growth in
Vermont with energy efficiency or
renewables and have at least five
percent renewables by 2012 over the 2004
baseline no RPS kicks in and and so the
incentive was out there for the
utilities to start developing renewables
and and everybody including the
Renewable community said gee this will
be enough no now they'll actually start
doing something in 2008 there was some
development but a couple of other things
happen that basically sort of changed
everybody's mind set number one energy
efficiency really was kicking in sir so
we were expecting we're having no low
growth and actually last year think
loads down three percent of course
recession helped a lot on that but even
before that the energy efficiency
programs that are run in Vermont now
pretty much eliminated most almost all
low growth in the state and beyond that
some of the renewables that had been
developed early on in particular by a
couple of utilities were going to cover
the entire five percent so the all the
incentives in this program didn't seem
to be working to have this wonderful
spur of renewable development and and
and get a lot more proposals out there
with me you know we do have in front of
us or do we have approved at the public
service board to wind facilities
but they they've gotten hung up on
financing issues and haven't been built
yet so in 2008 the legislature decided
to go a little farther and say okay
instead of having this incentive we want
the you public service board to develop
a rate for renewable projects that will
encourage them but still maintain be
consistent with least cost principles
given the most renewable development is
more costly than then other alternatives
huh market that was a little bit of a
challenge we looked at that for a little
bit and given that they passed the bill
in the middle of the year by January
they're already impatient that we didn't
have tons of development so they took
the whole thing out of the public
service boards hands and set up the
standard offer program and and let me
just state that the standardized we
think it's an important distinction
between a standard offer and feed-in
tariff it's not a tariff per se one
thing to keep in mind i'm going to put
my lawyer hat on is that the tariffs for
wholesale services and these are
wholesale products are regulated federal
level so if the state wanted to actually
do the tariff we couldn't because it
becomes a state tariff and it would be
an attempted to state terror but it
wouldn't be our jurisdiction so we
couldn't do it and then the utilities
would actually be the one that's going
to FERC and if they didn't actually want
to do it our leverage to make him do
anything was fairly limited the standard
offer program by contrast makes use of
the state essentially buying the power
and distributing it to all the other
utilities we have an entity called the
speed facilitator who was put in place
when the whole program was first put
gotten up and running in 2005 his goal
riginal II was to try to go out and make
deals and encourage deals between the
Renewable developers and utilities and
didn't really produce much but his role
was expanded by the legislature to now
offering the standard offer contracts
the the legislature thought that also
got around the jurisdictional problems
there's an open question there there
certainly some questions as to whether
we in fact are engaging in wholesale
operations but nobody's raised that so
far and as part of the standard offer
program what the legislature directed us
to do was to have a 50 megawatt program
for small small renewable development
maximum size 2.2 megawatts have it have
programmed these offers available until
that that 50 megawatts was filled and we
were supposed to set rates based upon
cost the rates that we offered by the
speed facilitator were based upon cost
not least cost principles and so if the
cost of a solar project was at least get
to the prices in a minute it was thirty
cents we're supposed to send set a rate
of thirty cents per kilowatt hour for
that solar project even though the
market price at the time the bill passed
was somewhere around seven cents and now
is believed in New England's around four
and a half cents is the market clearing
price that you can see see a major gap
here in terms of what we're paying under
this program and what the alternatives
are in the market the other part of this
is this be facilitator who is under
contract to us the public service board
and for those of you who we have a
different name every most other states
call it the Public Utilities Commission
same thing
there are some different splits in
Vermont that make it different but we're
the equivalent of the Public Utilities
Commission in most other states the
speed facilitator works for us and he
buys the power and then distributes it
to all the other utilities so it gets
shared among all the other utilities so
that that gets around the issue of well
this utility doesn't want to buy these
solar projects because it's going to
raise its rates everybody in its it's
essentially a public benefit of a public
sharing type program so in terms of
pricing in order to encourage this what
what the statute requires is that we
said set the prices that the program
will pay based upon the cost so we look
at costs both direct install cost
operation maintenance costs financing
costs you may have to make assumptions
on what's it going to cost the finance
and and we actually had the litigated
case where we heard evidence on on all
these things which was fairly
entertaining you include a reasonable
return on the investment built into that
and then you make adjustments for you
known revenue streams that they're going
to have such as grants and in the end
you make a final adjustment which is
enough to encourage rapid development
but not too much which some people came
to start calling the Goldilocks standard
it's not clear exactly what that meant
it basically gave us discretion to to to
adjust the rates up and down and this
took effect last June June of 2009 what
the legislature also did was told us we
had to have the program up and running
by September by the end of September so
they gave us a grand total of three
months to get this whole new program up
and running we missed the date by a
little bit we got got the first bids in
and first proposals in in October is
when we open the program up they do set
in the statute default prices the
default prices 30
cents per kilowatt-hour for solar 20
cents for small wind and wind 15
kilowatt Celeste 12 cents for landfill
methane and 12 and a half cents for
other renewable sources and said those
prices are going to be the initial
prices unless you bored by mid-september
in three months tell it you know to find
that they're completely wrong and in
three months we had time to look enough
to say now they're in there at least in
the ballpark except we raised the farm
methane price from 12 and a half to 16
cents following that we were required to
have a detailed evaluation of the prices
and actually set them bottom-up by
january fifteenth we met that deadline
the result of that was the solar drop
from 3224 all the prices all the prices
came down a little bit farm methane from
16 to 14.1 landfill methane down to 9
and the rest are somewhere right around
12 cents per kilowatt hour again the
markets still four and a half cents the
the program was opened the results of
the program it was opened up in October
19th is when we opened it for bids on
the first day the program was open we
had bids for 47 megawatts of power
actually we had bids for 160 megawatts
but we had set up sub caps so that no
one technology could be more than 12 and
12 and a half megawatts because we had
some suspicions that solar was going to
flood flood the system and in fact we
got 185 bids for solar for somewhere
around 169 megawatts I think most of us
looked at those numbers and said gee I
think we got the solar price a little
too high with that kind of demand but
the whole program 47 megawatts
within the sub gaps filled on the first
day within two weeks we had filled the
hole 50 megawatts of the program the
average size who is nearly one megawatt
each so these are some with the two and
a half or 2.2 megawatt cap these are
more sizable facilities they're you know
they're not to know your homeowner size
or farm size developments for the most
part these are these are much larger
except obviously the farm methane
programs which are farm size the the
projects are now working their way
through the approval process and some
are actually up and running some of
those are going to drop out we know we
know they're going to drop out they're
not going to get financing and then
we'll have to deal with who moves into
the program but so far I think the
effect of the higher prices has achieved
what the legislature wanted the flip
side is the estimate to that we heard
during during our proceeding is that
it's going to be a net incremental cost
to run rate payers 252 million dollars
over the next 20 years small numbers by
for those of you in states that are
bigger than Vermont which is pretty much
everybody those are really small dollars
but in Vermont that's not an not an in
substantial amount that's a it's a
pretty good above market premium that
you're paying and that's the ultimate
Bennett you know ultimate trade-off is
when they start flowing flowing through
into electrical rates what are people
going to say you know it's one of the
one of the big conundrums I think
everybody with renewable energy faces is
you ask people they want it yep how much
more than willing to pay
it gets a little fuzzier and we'll see
what the effect is it'll you know it'll
be several years before the effect
starts flowing through into rate so you
know get filtered in slowly but then
we'll see what happens so I'll stop
there great thank you one thing I was
remiss in mentioning and I'm going to
read this before we go into QA the event
sessions and their QA will be video
recorded by yael with the intent of
posting to youtube for public viewing
and by participating in the QA audience
members acknowledge that their questions
will be included so Thank You panelists
I thought that was excellent up I think
we're fortunate to hear about
experiences that are perhaps more than
just first-generation communities and
states that are that have been at this
for some time and I think are perhaps
suggesting some areas of interest in
questions questions around whether
there's sufficient demand to to bring
these to scale questions of what what it
might take to get a secondary market
built around these products and why
don't we why don't we turn it over to
all of you for for questions and
discussion
anyone wait we've answered every
question okay not preempted because
every I just over on the side here
Thanks hi my name is Kristen trots and I
am a second year at the Yale School of
Forestry and I'm curious it sounds in
each of your experiences that you had a
active role played by the legislature or
the equivalent body and in your
situation and I'm curious if if you
believe that there are drivers for
programs like these in places where
there's not state support are there are
there other drivers that can lead to the
establishment of these types of programs
that are not wholly backed by the state
well you're the state guys I could tell
you that that's my biases to be as
independent as possible we you know we
developed our program in the Sahara the
debt of the Bush years and I think the
self-reliance that we've had to instill
in our program has made it a stronger
program we are continuing as we've done
from the outset to look for market-based
solutions and get away from as much you
know government input as possible we
will leave others to go through the
process where we're sort of again as
I've animated less process oriented than
and there plenty of people who are
willing to carry the water on that we
just prefer to get the job done so you
know we'll continue to look for partners
and four mechanisms that will enhance
that principle and just for more from my
perspective and I think from I can speak
from the states our state's perspective
the Legislature's role in this one was
key but that was not not so much an
absence of willingness to go forward as
we're creature of state law and we have
to comply with state law and everything
we do and some of the principles that
have been embedded in state law for
years our principal such as least cost
provision of energy service and we fall
to utilities when they enter into
contracts that aren't least cost when
you're stand for something like a
renewable standard and when you're going
to pay
somebody 30 cents or 24 cents per
kilowatt-hour for solar when you can buy
it for four and a half cents if utility
had done that before this statute we
probably would have said gee that's not
warranted now but that that having been
said for years we've pushed the envelope
to take into account non monetary cost
considerations as we call them
externalities and we've had an
externality adjustments for 20 years in
Vermont taking into account environment
unpriced externalities such as air
emissions I'm not sure we fully captured
the FGM probably reasonably certain that
in some of those we haven't fully
captured the value of carbon and climate
change that's that's a very tough but
but certainly we take that into account
for you know so for example we've
approved one utility paying an extra six
cents for solar for solar before this
because it was likely to be on on peak
and because it was on on peak it
actually had a different cost
characteristic than a normal market
purchase and it was more likely to be
cost effective so we've pushed the
envelope but we're stuck with complying
with state law which has the least cost
principles which is ratepayers by the
way most of us want we don't want to
fight for gold plated facilities so
therefore the Legislature's role was
absolutely key in telling us to either
abandon those principles or exactly what
to do because otherwise we not being
complying with our duties I am gave to
Bosh the yield schooled management you
touched very slightly on sort of the
idea of base bonds or base bonds as you
call them and actually the Jacka dari
who I believe was was involved in coming
up with the original idea behind based
bonds presented presented the idea at
the school management just just a month
ago the name was Jack Hadari oh hey Jack
it here we go yeah so he's it seemed I
think to everyone there there's really
elegant idea and it and it sort of dealt
with
lot of the principal-agent issues that
you see in investment to the sort I'm
wondering from your perspective or
frankly any one's perspective here what
the what some of the challenges are
being adopted on a much wider scale yeah
sure I mean I'll very briefly say we
have obviously not had to deal with that
we developed a model that is working
with no security we understand the
appeal of that the challenge that we see
in that is you need to get many many
municipalities to each implement such a
program and you have to work through
whether municipalities have the
resources to be generating revenue
streams others getting into capital
markets that's something that most
smaller municipalities are going to be
challenged to do I think you also have
to then get them to put together the
infrastructure to start including the
additional building component and the
collection associated with that and then
I suppose the other issue is whether
municipalities when push comes to shove
and I don't want to sound like I'm
opposed to playing devil's advocate but
I mean it's pallies are going to start
foreclosing on properties because
someone's not paying thirty five dollars
a month towards their energy costs in
which case at which point is it any more
secure than an unsecured loan and having
to put an awful lot of process around
something that doesn't provide any
additional security for the investment
good so I think I also we also view it
as a pretty promising mechanism I think
there are a few areas of concern for for
us that we and our PRC I think one of
them is that these are voluntary
programs so the proposition has to be
clear enough and compelling enough for a
property owner to you know to take that
leap and it's not clear to us yet that
there you know that this has been
socialized sufficiently that there's
enough you know demand to get get to
scale but there's a lot of effort I
think underway by many groups to to make
that happen I think there's a lot of
discussion about the tension between the
lean
and the mortgage holder in terms of what
happens in a stress case what happens in
a foreclosure and and the implications
for mortgage holders in terms of where
they fall in line in terms of the flow
of payments and and I think related to
that which is interesting is that I
think the information there's a there's
an information disparity in terms of the
information about the lean and how the
financial community sees it and it's
available to them and information around
cost savings and I think today if you're
a mortgage broker looking at the
refinancing of a property and that
property has a pace lean on it you only
see the lien you don't you don't see the
cost savings that's associated with it
and and frankly you might not even be
aware of you know what what what the
mechanism is so I think in general I
think there's a lot of for lack of a
better word socializing around the
concept that needs to take place but I
think there's there's there are many
reasons a compelling reasons to make
that happen in lots of groups that I
think are active in trying to you know
to overcome these rules just jump on
that last part for one second the
interesting thing is that that's the
exact same obstacle that the people have
been pushing for energy efficient energy
efficient mortgages have been unable to
overcome for probably a decade and a
half now the fact that that they want
the reduction in household operating
expenses associated with a much tighter
house to be reflected in the borrower's
FICO score and and banks and lenders
will have not yet agreed to do that so
all they see is that the house cost
twenty thousand dollars more to make it
real tight they don't see that it
returns two thousand dollars less an
annual costs associated with the savings
from that so if this is in particular
that's that's an existing problem that
no one's solved yet I'm sorry me too no
no no no no I think that's a great point
you look up there 17 states that have
passed various kinds of pace legislation
to data is probably aware because
seems like you've been following this
you know I know in New York there was
quote unquote paste legislation passed
in November that had been pushed by
actually our congressman but it was
really contingent on a lot of other
enabling bits of legislation
particularly the federal level so you
don't have those kind of price supports
for example that are elemental to them
we actually had legislation in all
fairness I to this young lady's question
before our local Assemblyman and state
senator had gotten legislation to
actually affirm the principle that we
have using a waste district to do waste
reduction so in effect in New York State
you if you either have a waste district
which many people may miss colonies do
you can do this or if you want to you
can create a waste district you do this
kind of work and in fact that gives you
the validation to then go out and do
various kinds of financing as far as
bonding is concerned again you know it
gets back to you know what kind of rates
are you getting is this the ideal
vehicle at this particular point in time
for this particular application what
when we're looking at now they were
bought a larger numbers and the the
financial guides by the way we were the
first ones to tell us when they when we
created this unwittingly I must say in
all due difference to Jack Henry the
wonderful guy success has a hundred
followers and I would success i would
suggest this page program has a maybe a
thousand fathers circling around it
right now but we unwittingly as i said
developed this same principle without
knowing what the acronym was ultimately
going to be and we only found out how
good it was when you know the big-money
guys like Bruce came talking to us
because we wanted to move to a
market-based model and they said you
know we're more than eager to get behind
you on this but you got to have at least
30 million aggregated can you guys can
you guys figure out how to go through
neighborhoods the same way you like
repave roads and get like a hundred
houses at a time doing it on the same
day and we just looked at him cross-eyed
but the principle is yes we have to get
to know these aggregated levels before
you know those kinds of principles kick
in but for us at the point in time where
we are based upon the other programs
that are developing around us we're
going to actually bond for two milk two
million but we're going to use
los reserved to then attract a debt and
equity capital that's that's the
principle we're going to be pursuing and
we're not going to be funding this
entirely out of government bonds and so
on so forth I just don't think that's a
long-term sustainable solution the
partnership is a key and figuring that
one out okay so Leslie just oh we have
time for one more question she brought
in are you hooking us up well one more
question okay thank you a creek a very
quick question please like the question
for you mr. Woltz about the the program
that you were describing and just that
sounds like there's a disconnect between
the rate of return that's acceptable to
the Commonwealth and what's acceptable
in the market this a percent or nine
percent that's that you're willing to
you know to take and then the market is
demanding 14 or for 12 or 14 or whatever
the percentages how do you see like
these how do you see your this program
moving forward you know how do you how
are you going to be able to sell these
these loans with that disconnect are you
going to be have to take a well of them
at a discount or essentially what your
let's accept your statement of the facts
that there's some things I could go
straight up it's a tight it's a fair
read of what I said and we don't need to
clarify that what you're really
describing is a monopoly situation right
now given that there's no one else able
to aggregate the only place these lungs
are able to go in a flow-through basis
is fannie mae fannie mae therefore as a
monopoly control and is essentially
demanding the yield that it's able to
demand so the goal of creating a
secondary market which I talked about at
the very end of my remarks is in fact to
create alternatives to fannie mae at
much lower rates if we can demonstrate
that these loans perform and when an
address investors concerns about
security perhaps by adding a pace
component or a non built a mint
component or any of the other things and
generate a yield of seven or eight
percent then investors may be willing to
take them out at seven or eight percent
and then
may has to either stop doing it or
become more competitive so you're
absolutely right that is exactly the
problem that's that that is represented
by the absence of a secondary market and
that's we're hoping to address is that
responsive so join me in thanking our
panelists both for being here today and
for their leadership